[музика]
[оплески]
сіяти і орати грієм врожай збирати
Україна то наша земля
нам чужого ніц не треба Коби сонце й
синє небо Україна то наша земля
та як зайти Круть до хати зможемо всіх
їх прикопати окупанту бетоном земля
пам'ятай
хто цілий день з мечем відзначає загине
хто на тому палити вогнем згорить у
вогні наші воїни єдині в городі за
Україну вовк тут ми у своїй державі на
своїй землі
вмієм бити тянет човенно байрактаром
Україна то наша земля
кожен город має знати українців не
здолати Україна то наша земля
як нас б'ють дає моста чи московитом не
пробачень окупанту бетоном Земля
ніхто сюди прийти з мечем і означає
загине там надума палити вогнем свою
вогні наші воїни єдині в боротьбі за
праділок тут ми у своїй державі на своїй
землі
[музика]
[оплески]
це само нікому свого у нас чекає
перемога Україна то наша земля
чорнобаївським звичаєм восковитів
покараєм Україна то наша земля
єдині як ніколи в нашій селі наші волі
Україна Мамо ти в нас одна
прийди з мечем від начала загине хто
надумалити вогнем дзвонить у вогні наші
воїни єдині в боротьба країну бо тут ми
у своїй державі на своїй землі
лютий прийде з мечем він ночай загине
хто насмахали диводем згорить у вогні
наші воїни
єдині в боротьбі за Вкраїну тут ми у
своїй державі на своїй землі
тут ми у своїй державі на своїй землі
тут на своїй державі на своїй землі
[музика]